[Applause]
[Music]
well that's it
Game of Thrones is over while the show
is anyway so I'm Fire and Ice well he
may never end depends on how long takes
the guy to write it but the show's done
seen the last episode that was an odd
experience spent about the first half of
it right up until at spoilers like
massive spoilers so there's your warning
right up until Daenerys got killed
basically sighing and going why is this
so stupid and then the second half of it
going oh well that's all right then
and I don't mean that in like it made
everything that didn't work about the
season suddenly work it didn't but as
far as how it wrapped up who ended up
where yeah kind of works so let's start
at the front half though let me get my
complaints out of the way so that I can
be done with them John's a friggin idiot
like eventually yes he does what he has
to do but like why is he even right okay
look a big part of the problem with this
for me is that I never bought the
relationship between Danny and John I
just didn't their chemistry is absolute
crap and for my money like the number of
times they were actually in the same
space together was actually not a lot
between when they met and when they were
so in
with each other oh god I hate that crap
so like I never bought this relationship
and somewhat like so much of what's been
going on lately in the first half of
this final episode especially is all
hinged on that and it really just hurt
to watch so I'm watching John go through
this whole big exaggerated painful
journey realizing what he has to do and
the show acting like he didn't have a
nearly comparable experience with a gret
what was five seasons ago well I'm being
depending on when you want to take him
for when she shot him in the back or
when he watched her die
but in any case the fact that it never
comes up that this is not completely
alien territory for him or at the very
least possibly acknowledged I've been
through crap like this before I don't
know if I can do it again that would
have been something instead the show
acts like this is something he's never
had to do it yes he freakin has and he
had way better chemistry with her than
he does with Danny
so it really infuriated me when Tyrians
in jail like first of all Tyrion look
who are you trying to prove a point to
when you decided to defy Daenerys and
like throw your thing down like who was
left to impress with that little thing
like who was that symbolic gesture meant
for and anyway so Tyrion in jail being
dumb because Tyrion has been dumb lately
and then Josh shows up and they get into
this conversation and Jon is defending
Daenerys not in like gay hell he's so
he's not talking to Tyrion and like to
help me find the strength he's he's
serious just all he's doing is telling
Jon the things she did he's not even
making an argument against Danny he's
just saying the things that happened and
John is there defending her and I'm
sorry that doesn't come across like him
being torn that comes across like him as
a freaking idiot I think he got Daenerys
with her big we're going to live
right the world and given would her
current idea of liberation is yeah we
know what that means and I'm assuming
she must have been in it last episode
maybe I didn't notice because she was on
the dragon the whole time and the
Dragons more or less black I didn't
realize they decked her out in black
leather Oh God when I saw her stroll up
at this point she's in full I will
destroy the world mode she's in there's
black leather like oh my freaking God
of course the iron throne is still
standing after having a freaking tower
collapse on to it yeah naturally ooh I
get to claim Greta on this one I called
that the iron throne was gonna get
melted down I have been caught I've been
saying that for a couple of years now
that when this thing ends that throne
will not exist anymore so I got that one
but it was it was the turnaround moment
of the show when when Danny and John
kiss because my initial reaction that
was oh come on
and then he stabs our I'm like oh good
and then we get into the second half
which is it's weird because on the one
hand it's a little boring but I mean
it's it's a coda it's a wrap up it's an
epilogue practically so it's not gonna
be exciting and more to the point if
this show was ever gonna have it was
never gonna have an ending that felt
like an ending it was gonna have to end
in a way that things are boring
now which I suppose makes brand the
perfect King because bran is frigging
boring and the funny thing is like after
or Tyrion has spent most of the seasons
definitely the first half of this
episode just being dumb he shows up and
makes a legitimately good argument in
favor of brand not bad I am kind of glad
that Sam's idea got laughed down of
installing a democracy that would have
been a rolling but I do like that Tyrion
actually makes a good argument there the
North is now
independent you know so Sansa gets to
control up there we meet we meet the new
small Council which is made up of all
characters who I like while Tyrians
tarry and I'm kind of fed up with but
the rest of the characters I like I like
Davos I like bran I like Sam
I like Brienne yeah I'm good with these
people and I'm looking at who's in
charge and are you just going off to see
what what else is out there that she can
find and John back up at the wall which
honestly just feels right and I can look
at all of this and go this is a good
place for everyone to end getting here
has been a bit of a mess especially this
year like so what what it really feels
like especially with this being a short
season and especially with some of the
character turns that happen and how
rapidly some stories got got closed off
you really do feel like the makers of
this wanted to be done and they had an
endpoint that was a good endpoint but in
an effort to get there and to be done
with it and to not have to do this show
anymore they just rushed getting here
so I would still say that this season
has an execution issue I would say this
episode second half of the episode at
least actually really doesn't but the
payoff for a lot of this stuff doesn't
land as well as it could or really
should given that these are good places
for these things to end these were good
shots for these things then these were
good moments for these characters and
but instead of leaving me fully
satisfied which it could have done
coming on the back of properly paced and
executed season and instead leaves me
going oh well oh I didn't 100% drop the
ball at the tail end okay okay cool so
what what should have been a more
triumphant like ah so satisfying it was
more a bit of a soothing balm
so yeah this I don't know if I'll do a
video like over viewing my thoughts on
season 8 I'm debating that because I'm
not I could go on like longer but I
think ultimately it just comes down to
the writing was just rushed and whether
like I don't I doubt it was HBO who said
you only get six episodes I wouldn't be
surprised if the writers went no we only
need six to wrap this up I'm because I
really suspect HBO was gonna give them
pretty much whatever they wanted but
whoever's call it was whether it was the
the show producers or HBO itself whoever
made the decision only six episodes this
season that really heard it because so
much of what is trying to pay off in
this isn't totally landing because the
turns to get there are too sudden and
the number of storylines that are
wrapping up are all piling up on top of
each other so we can't appreciate them
the way that we could if it was just a
couple to an episode as opposed to
dumping a whole ton of resolution and
bait Masek mainly into the previous
episode so the season has not been great
honestly even this episode was not great
but if I look at the home stretch if I
look at how it chose to wrap everything
up that I'm gonna see it I don't know if
this makes any sense but it wrapped up
well but just at the very end and not in
a way that redeems the stumbles just in
a way that keeps it from being an
absolute complete faceplant of the order
of you know Dexter you know it it
doesn't III don't mean to dwell on it
but like the ending to Dexter is so bad
that it it ruins even the good I hope
you can hear the rain it's been
thunderstorm in here anyways the ending
Dexter so bad that it actually makes it
where I can't even really enjoy the good
seasons as much as I used to because of
how badly that box is the ending this
isn't that it's still not a good last
season but in terms of how the story
concludes honestly it feels right so for
the ending of this show this season has
been a disappointment in terms of how
the stories wrap up honestly I think
it's pretty solid is this kind of it
though like if the if this had been a
solid season this ending would have been
a great ending since this season has not
been a solid season the ending is simply
oh well that's pretty good and that's
where I end up Game of Thrones it's done
my favorite house got wiped out a couple
years ago so you know but in any case
what are your thoughts on it whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there is a
whole bunch of stuff to do because
there's buttons and links and there's
the patreon which has rewards like you
get to vote and help decide topics as
discord there's ton of other stuff check
that out I've got merch there's other
links to my social medias click on
things it'll take you places but you
also don't have to cuss at the end of
the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]